La computación responsable se entiende
como el desarrollo de la computación cuántica
con conciencia de su poder
y sus posibles impactos. Cuando hablamos de responsabilidad,
nos referimos a desarrollar y usar tecnología
basada en principios predefinidos que nos ayuden a prevenir
y mitigar posibles daños,
promoviendo al mismo tiempo soluciones que sean de forma proactiva
inclusivas y responsables. En IBM,
hemos tenido un sentido de responsabilidad
hacia la sociedad durante décadas. Hoy nos llamamos un catalizador
que hace que el mundo funcione mejor. Eso significa que
tenemos la responsabilidad de considerar las implicaciones de
las tecnologías que construimos y ayudamos a poner en uso.
Mientras desarrollamos esta nueva tecnología,
las decisiones que tomamos hoy influirán en el futuro,
y estas decisiones
tienen el potencial de generar un enorme impacto en la sociedad.
Por ejemplo, puede que tengas que decidir si perseguir una aplicación
que beneficia solo a unos pocos interesados, o
una que podría resolver un problema social.
Esperamos que tú, como cliente, seas capaz de pensar
en el desarrollo responsable de la computación cuántica.
Pensar de forma responsable puede ayudar a tu empresa a generar confianza
con inversores y consumidores,
además de construir una reputación de integridad
y admiración entre tus empleados
y clientes. Por otro lado,
puede ayudarte a protegerte de mala prensa, multas
y sanciones. En este video,
presentaremos consideraciones importantes sobre responsabilidad
para discutir con tu equipo
mientras exploras la computación cuántica
y sus aplicaciones. Cuando se trata de computación cuántica,
pensar y actuar de forma responsable
significa seguir un conjunto de principios
y valores que guíen tu desarrollo
y despliegue de tecnología.
Por ejemplo, esto significa ser transparente
tanto sobre las limitaciones como las capacidades
de la computación cuántica. Hoy contamos con lenguaje
en nuestros contratos que requiere que los clientes de IBM Quantum
usen nuestros sistemas de forma responsable
y que no utilicen nuestros sistemas
con fines nefastos o ilegales.
A estas cláusulas las llamamos de uso responsable
y uso aceptable.
Este lenguaje ya está influyendo en cómo nuestros clientes piensan
sobre el desarrollo cuántico
para sus casos de uso. También podemos
ayudar a influir en la dirección de la computación cuántica
decidiendo qué aplicaciones impulsamos
para su desarrollo y aceleración.
Para protegernos contra posibles usos irresponsables
de nuestra tecnología, también hemos desarrollado una robusta tecnología IBM Quantum
segura. Mientras piensas en cómo
y para qué usar la computación cuántica,
asegúrate de hablar con realismo sobre tus expectativas
respecto a la computación cuántica y los plazos
en los que esperas incorporarla.
No presentes la computación cuántica
como algo misterioso; intenta explicarla de forma realista
como hardware informático
que sigue las leyes de la física cuántica.
Asegúrate de que tu caso de uso de computación cuántica
sea proactivamente inclusivo
y que considere a todos los posibles interesados
para determinar el alcance
de cualquier impacto social negativo.
Asegúrate de tener principios claramente definidos
y valores para la exploración de tu caso de uso
y su desarrollo. Gracias
por ver este video. Esperamos que,
al llevar la computación cuántica útil al mundo,
también pienses en cómo hacerlo de forma responsable.
El el